let me pull up this story we have this
from CNN World
explosion of C excuse me explosion of
sea lion deaths in Peru amid deadly bird
flu outbreak so now what are they saying
thousands of sea lions in Peru have died
amid an outbreak of bird flu bird flu is
not only passed into mammals it's
passing into many other mammals this is
a 60 mortality rate
I'm sure the most conspiracy-minded
individuals are thinking that it was all
intentional but I've got to say guys if
you think that they took bird flu and
then did gain of function research to
make it transmissible among mammals I
have to say you're completely right from
science.org controversial experiments
that could make bird flu more risky
poised to resume to gain of function
projects halted more than four years ago
have passed new U.S review processes so
uh in February of 2019 and we have
mentioned this before they began working
on h5n1 to make it transmissible among
mammals now why would you go and do that
and now it is bouncing around mammals
and it does have a 60 mortality rate
that's correct they actually did it the
first time back in 2011 they did it and
uh for a while they tried to stop
publishing it but they ultimately ended
up letting letting them publish and I'll
explain why they do it why the
government does that I just don't want
your bloggers to take my head off for
defending them but this is why the
government you're going to take your
head off no matter what I know this is
why the government does gain a function
research they do it with this reasoning
hey
eventually h5n1 will mutate to become
human human transmissible it'll happen
naturally and biologists have said that
and they're right it happens all the
time virus is always mutating so they
say what we're going to do is we're
going to speed it up in the lab we're
going to develop a human human
contagious or mammal to mammal
contagious version now once we've got
this in the lab we'll keep it in the lab
and we'll develop vaccines so when the
natural happens we'll prepare that's
their argument for doing it but the
problem here is back in 2011 I don't
care if they do that at Fort Dietrich
which by the way isn't too far from you
you know if the Army's doing biological
research for defensive Reasons I'm for
that but when they released it and
publish how you do it so that anyone
from Al-Qaeda to North Korea to Syria
you name it I could do it I've got the
knowledge it's low-tech way to do it and
you publish results now you've just
increased our odds of any nut case doing
it and then releasing it so it's
happening naturally but the threat is
not low that's that's what I was arguing
here the threat is not low because a
natural mutation maker the threat is
high because it has mutated it is now
spreading amongst mammals it started
with minks last year sea lions other
things may be spreading now but they're
not the only threat you could
deliberately do it in a lab you could
deliberately do it a low-tech way in the
basement I'm saying bad guys could be
doing it now too because we've published
how to do it it's very well known so to
me it's inevitable biologists have used
that word in Congressional testimony
warning Congress we must be ready for
Avian fluid h5n1 to be spreading amongst
humans they've been warning Congress for
a decade now has anything been done not
a damn thing what can they do just like
that there's a lot of things that if one
thing to do the first thing is just warn
people don't have the CDC saying oh it's
low risk it's not low risk all kinds of
medical groups are saying watch out it's
coming the probability of a pandemic has
gone up but the CDC keeps it in Center
for Disease Control keeps saying it's
low and it's not and the CDC is not
giving an honest warning about it the
threat is up a lot because it's now
mutated and it's now spreading amongst
mammal populations which means as that
virus mutates it's far more likely when
it's mutating amongst sea lions or
ferrets or mink to now become human
human transmissible so the risk is up it
is not still low risk like they've been
saying can you calculate that risk no
you can't you can't put a number to it
but that's why the CDC absolutely cannot
say it's low risk it's an unknown risk I
think it could be very high probability
it could be 50 percent it's going to
happen this year 75 percent CDC cannot
know that so why are they announcing its
low risk to humans when you cannot know
that without going into great detail let
me just say I think the people who watch
this show I think myself personally I'm
pretty sure the other people in the room
have very little faith in the CDC for a
variety of reasons yeah the CDC wants to
prevent Panic one which is why they'll
say don't worry about it secondly when
it comes to covid the way they handle
covet they did not talk about
prophylactic measures they never really
talked about prevention they talked
about how to deal with it once it
already hits I don't want to eject the
thing or do the thing where's the
vitamin D I don't want to deviate from
the bird flu so this is why I think we
haven't heard about how to prevent or
prepare for how to heal from this stuff
before it gets you because I if the
methodology is let's heal it once it
strikes I think the CDC is completely
inept or malicious and they're incapable
of properly advising it was so bad that
Stephen Crowder got multiple strikes and
it's not just them it's you know the big
tech industry uh Stephen Crowder got to
think two strikes on YouTube for talking
about what the CDC was saying that's how
insane the whole thing is generally let
me let me just say about all of this I
don't think anyone is going to give us
an honest assessment of what this is and
what might happen but I will say I do
believe based on what we've already seen
well I should say this the news is
reported the gain of function research
to make bird flu transmissible among
mammals happened a decade ago and they
kept doing it and how and and now that
the department of energy and the FBI are
saying lab leak how hard would it be for
this to leak from a lab accidents happen
or Worse still as you mentioned bad guys
can do it very easily sure and bad guys
can take out of a lab very easily they
should not be doing these things we've
been warning people our members we've
been putting on our newsletter you need
to be prepared because there's so many
ways this could happen if I were Putin
you know a ruthless guy not doing well
in the Ukraine war and the U.S and West
European providing so much support if he
releases clandestinely so you can't even
punish him for it he releases a virus
like avian flu human human transmissible
over here we are not going to be
supporting Ukraine we're going to be
struggling to survive losing tens
perhaps hundreds of millions of people
over here we're not helping Ukraine he
now has a free reign there and if he's
developed the virus he may already have
the vaccine developed so he can give it
to Russian people he wants to survive
and for the rest of the world they
suffer the worst pandemic the worst
disaster in human history what our some
prophylactic measures that people can
take to protect themselves
masks aren't going to work the only
thing you can do is you have to stay
away from people and tell the virus
plays out now here's this is a bad news
good news the good news is when you have
a virus this lethal it's going to kill
people 60 lethal it's going to kill
people so massively people are going to
immediately isolate for long periods of
time and the virus will die out fairly
quickly the viruses it's it's not good
for a virus to have super high lethality
because you end up killing off your
virus you can't survive well if it's low
level like covet or flu you keep you
keep spreading it all the time this you
will not you will have to be isolated
for at least months perhaps over a year
so you've got to have food and the
ability to defend your food which is the
other reason why there's no warning of
this coming out if you weren't about a
collapse you have to warn about maraud
or threats it happened in Katrina it's
certainly going to happen if the grid is
down and there's food product it's going
to happen you got to have guns well I
talk about and the government is not
going to tell people hey you need to
have a lot of guns and by the way
assault rifles and those high capacity
magazines that's what you need if you're
going to defend against Marauders no no
don't don't uh misinterpret he said
assault rifle with high capacity
magazines we're talking fully automatic
select fire with 100 round drums or
something like that and he said yeah he
said
he settles with an S so multiple that's
way more than one now if you want to
mention something like a standard
semi-auto standard capacity we're
talking about an AR-15 with 30 round
magazines that's not what he said he
said well you can't even buy those in
Colorado those are illegal Clips in
Colorado so you buy them in Nebraska
elsewhere
they come in illegally with them and
like what I think what he was saying is
like a 50 BMG
um you know mounted uh butterfly trigger
let me know what you think about this I
was thinking Auto defense turrets you
know we'll build big towers and then
we'll have on them just Century turrets
that you know sweep left and right and
then at a certain time they will go into
you know full defense mode and if you uh
you know
you know I wouldn't recommend that I
just use you know people with weapons is
the low-cost smart way to do that but
you need a lot of people to defend
yourself in a collapse and you need
assault rifles and high capacity Clips
because there could be Marauder groups
that have 50 100 people in them we got
we got two million Americans in jail if
the electric grid goes down are you
going to keep two million people they're
going to come out they're not they're
going to stay and they're going to use
the prisons as fortresses and and they
need food there's not enough of course
scouting parties who come back to the
prisons because the prisons are
fortified and armed and you're not
breaking in and they can control like I
think real no one's raiding a prison and
prisons will be ready no realistically
the people will be locked in their cells
and they'll be left no because when the
power when the power goes off the
Shell's open the automatic that's
horrible the cell manufacturers
if the power goes off and there's no one
there you'll have you'll have people
dying yeah Katrina
but it doesn't matter when the when when
the system breaks someone's going to go
in from the outside and they're gonna
have friends and family who are in
prison and they are going to take that
whole place over and it is a fortress I
doubt it
it's also the most aggressive people in
society I feel like they'll all be dead
within a week in a city because the
doors lock and they all just starve all
the guards leave you're acting like
people in jail have no family
what do they get how are they going to
get in the building they're going to
drive their truck 100 miles an hour and
slam into a Walsh it's like eight eight
eight feet wide concrete prisons have
fences thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time